I just want you to know that I don't
care about whatever you're trying to
bait me into talking with you about and
then I need to do work today read you
loud and clear
attention everybody I just want to
apologize for not being the best friend
and co-worker to you guys and not the
best Kaelin to myself uh-huh I eat too
much I drink too much and I jetski too
much
oh you don't Jessica too much I might
even be a little bit inconsiderate but I
want you to know I am going to solve
literally all of my problems by starting
a juice cleanse
kaylynn juice cleanses aren't proven
today is the new beginning of a chapter
of man gonna be late to the meeting have
you noticed how good the light smells
today yeah I guess I think my third eye
opened up and ever since then I've
really been able to see everything for
what it really is yeah juice looks
really intense how do you want to try
some it'll change everything it's celery
stems and turnip dirt oh it's terrible
once your second mouth and nose open
you'll love it do you feel any different
I go to the bathroom about once every
eight minutes and sometimes when I dream
I dream that I'm a blue star riding a
sort of cosmic wave through the ever
expanding universe
cool you know I'm old Kaelyn would have
thought that that smelled delicious and
it it would have made his mouth water do
you want a bite no old Kaelyn was more
toxins than man we are new Kaelyn I'm
gonna be late to that meeting later
I think I like the new Kalin's did you
know that 9 out of 10 things you put in
your mouth are pure poison that's
completely false smell your light juice
cleanse juice cleanse juice cleanse
juice cleanse juice cleanse cleanse
cleanse cleanse cleanse juice cleanse
you know when you think about it the
primordial ooze that the first life came
out of that was like the first juice
okay
juice cleanse juice cleanse Jesus she
was close she was a little worried he's
not responding to my texts or anything I
know it's so great right she's crying
hey man I think you need this I pity you
the unclean is so what I call his
emergency contact I'm his emergency
contact yeah yes posted to Facebook okay
I think Kalyan has turned into the
monster on that plane in that one movie
I'm gonna be late to the meeting
you